this is just uh like there's different
degrees of
i i don't know what the
what the term would be but um
you've got people right now who are
saying no one should be allowed to go
outside because i'm scared of covet yeah
then you've got other people saying if
you're scared you stay home i'm gonna do
my thing
so there's varying degrees of like how
much freedom we should have versus how
much security and i think the difference
is you're all about total freedom yeah
even if it means you're not gonna be
you're gonna have people zooming patch
on the highway you're like well you know
i'm free right yeah i'm free
freedom has a strange definition like
total freedom
means that
you're out in the middle of no
we've created freedom in the united
states by
a military force so we're pretty we're
giving ourselves
freedom like you can walk around outside
without getting jumped and punched in
the middle no that's a cultural thing
dude it's because we have police
protection it's not it is if it was
total law lawlessness you could also
call that freedom i'd go out there and
urinate on your face and kick you in the
teeth and take your money and no one's
gonna stop me
i'm free
how do you do that with the ak strapped
to my back yeah right what if i get the
jump on you i mean you if you want to
fight for a living you're going to end
up getting beat down that's just the
problem i don't i don't think so so i
know the problem with you
oh i know the problem with you
you have no faith in people
i wouldn't say that that's everything
you said today you don't have faith in
people that can they keep driving fast
you don't you think that if the
government wasn't there somebody come
pee on your face
people would be hacking your bank
account you would have no recourse
that's but here's what you listen
when we're talking about being safe in
public that's not police
the police the police most people aren't
crazy outside you know who you know who
hacks your bank account
yeah seriously
so look i think
i don't i don't expect if i'm gonna be
walking on the street the reason
someone's not gonna hug me is because
cops exist that's not true we have the
death penalty people still commit these
crimes we know we have a lot more
i could take you down the block right
now you won't you won't walk back from
yeah
the cops the cops don't give a damn i
know what if the whole world was like
that that i mean they're crazy no
are you familiar with the wild wild west
i mean i know of it yeah was it wild or
was it peaceful
i think it was wild people get scalped
and murdered and shot it was it was
okay
everything you just said is a historical
what do you mean
the wild wild west was actually really
peaceful
for who
for everybody you'd walk into a town and
everybody was strapped up you were you
the last society
so it was like genociding the natives no
that's the government i mean it was that
the government sanctioned that the
natives would come scout people the
people would kill it was uh and it was
government natives were scouting bro
hold on hold on hold on where'd you get
your history from tv
i got some of it probably so hold on
hold on dude what do you think would
happen if you went to like north africa
in the middle east if you go to libya
right now
it's scalpel
and walked in
you're talking about going into like i'm
here you're going into
like uh
pure chaos not pure chaos but
when you're talking about
police right now in a heavily developed
and peaceful nation for the most part
crime has been on the decline for
several decades
the reason why you're not getting muggle
time is not because cops exist however i
do think cops serve a purpose in that
they they do and can stop violently and
they deter it as well so i think but but
for the most part the reason why you're
not getting mugged is because people
don't aren't going to mug you well
people are animals and when they get
hungry they go crazy so you got to keep
them people are desperate uh poverty
breeds crime and so you know we we we
can i don't know we can figure out ways
to solve cultural issues but for the
most part violent crime has been going
down the existence of police i don't
think is stopping you from getting
mugged because
people mug even though there is a
penalty even though there are cops that
can be called it's just that you know we
we are learning to live i got a
challenge for you
if we removed government what good would
happen
that's a good question
if it was just like no government at all
yeah what good can come from it
i could see when you when you talk about
removing the state everybody runs to the
extremes and the bad thing that can
happen and you can and the thing is the
way the the the human consciousness is
rigged today it's rigged to
automatically go to doubt and fear this
is old napoleon hill i got one for you
what's that if we got rid of the state
right now non-violent drug offenders
could go home to their families mm-hmm
boom see that's big and i think that
should happen and people were calling on
trump to do it but he didn't do it all
criminals would maybe
yeah for sure if we got rid of the state
all all president but
but the point he was making was
name a good thing did you hear what he
just did though he turned it into a bad
thing he did it again you want to well
if you want to remove prisons from the
equation completely open up all jails
that wasn't that that was the challenge
but the challenge was if you give me
like
a boss
nine venomous snakes and a chipmunk in
your life
i think there are way too many
non-violent drug offenders who should be
home with their families
and and we want to keep the violent
psychopathic
rapists and murderers
in prison you know i would need to
challenge that man because i think i
agree we should leave the non-violent
and i think the people in prison should
have better i think they should have
access to video games i don't believe i
i'll mess your head up i don't believe
in the prisons
so what do you what do you do when
someone you like serial killer
first of all if you have somebody who's
a known proven serial killer what we do
is we admit them to a psychotherapy
facility
and this is where
college kids get to train you get to
train on these so-called inmates but
they become case studies so we can learn
the brain and learn behavior more and we
introduce these people to
more nutritious environments
right and when i say nutritious it
doesn't mean
you know these four walls that are super
cold and you know you're locked down for
20 like what does that actually do for
the human mind
now are we going to set this person free
probably not
they're probably going to be imprisoned
imprisoned i would i've removed the word
imprisoned
i don't know what that word is i'd have
to incarcerate it or i would remove that
i would move that down too much you know
dogma comes with that stuff you know
we'd have to think about it
who would be imprisoning them though
let's let's let's just
i mean these are all these are all great
these are all great questions right
um but what i'm saying is
the institution of prison needs to be
revamped
it needs to be more about rehabilitation
and not imprisonment because the
majority of the people there aren't
there voluntarily they're there because
of circumstance the environment they
were brought up in that's pretty much
the only place they could end up is in
prison i'll tell you this if we if there
was no state we'd have a lot less serial
killers because everybody would be
strapped yep the way you put it yeah
i say i think i think most concerns are
probably agree with that everybody need
to be strapped up yo when you're born
when you're born a gun should come with
your diapers
we used to we don't have a lot of
documentation of the past but i think
there were a lot of serial killers in
the past and it was just normal oh dude
yeah probably people just walked around
and killed violence no one was there to
stop him yeah yeah we live in a very i
was reading i was reading uh i told this
story before i was at glenn beck's
studio and he's got these old newspapers
just mounted on the on on the walls and
i was reading one of them and it was
about some guy walked out of a bar and
then some other guy walking to the bar
and took a pistol like mid-1800s and
just put it to his chest and pulled the
trigger
no reason just did it but i'm like that
stuff happens in chicago all the time
man i grew up not all the time you know
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no that's a verbally for sure no it's
all the time yeah it's all the time
would mean non-stop everything every day
every day every day is different than
all the time so when i say all the time
you you are in a state where at any
point throughout the day it's gonna
happen and it happens almost every
single day so yeah i think it's fair to
say all the time it's just an extreme
statement it's not accurate no you're
just trying to argue so
what's your name one more time i'm
terrible with james ian
if i had you on my team you'd be quality
assurance we wouldn't bring you anything
until like me and tim sat down and i'd
be like okay tear this apart tell me
everything wrong with it right and i
think there's a lot of people that have
these trends some people optimist some
people are pessimists i would put you in
a pessimist category and i would say tim
us optimist let's get together wait wait
wait to be fair
ian's usually optimist i'm usually the
pessimist what i'm saying in the context
is of right first time i'm meeting him
and every time like i said say something
positive and he was like we're gonna die
pissed off right
you know in the context of this
conversation this is how our viewing is
right so i'm like i would take all the
optimists and say
if we didn't have government what good
could happen and we'd paint our flowers
over here then i'd bring it in and say
hey here's what we got tear it apart
then you'd write down everything that's
wrong with this and i'd go back to my
optimism all right how do we fix these
problems right yeah and that's how we
use each other but the the thing i i
believe is
you have to escape that that that
thinking momentarily and say i'm not
going to think about the bad that can
come because that's too easy
what's hard is to think about what good
can come that's hard and the and the
system has been
con has conditioned us
to think only about fear and to think
about like but you know don't think it
is a system i think it's human evolution
because in order to survive you have to
think about what's bad you can't really
spend a lot of thinking time thinking
about how nice that flower smelled when
there's a saber-toothed tiger behind you
you know what i'm saying so it's not
even necessarily cultural unless we're
talking about like the evidence
there's a point to be made there but
when we're done dealing with
a media who exasperates fear yeah well
they know right like yeah like they take
something that's carnal
and then they just
set fire to it and just you know pour
gasoline on it they they gaslight us you
know what you know you know what the
problem is
the problem is the media is giving us
fake hardship yes real hardship is a
good thing yes like when you get kids
who grow up with snowplow parents who
are pushing all the obstacles out of
their way they grow up they can't
survive properly right then you get
these people and the media screams in
their faces non-stop the orange man is
bad right and then their whole identity
becomes the world is ending the sky is
falling yeah because they they didn't go
look you know why i don't when trump got
elected i laughed in 2016 i just put my
feet up and i was laughing yeah because
yeah i'd have a youtube video i'm just
laughing
because dude i've been through through
hardships where i'm like this is not the
biggest problem anybody's saying and
they're like but he's gonna take
people's rights away it's like dude you
do not remember anything about politics
or what goes on you know nothing about
like living in a city like chicago these
suburb kids think they have it bad
because the tv told them it's true yeah
they need to go out and go camping for a
couple weeks just like get back to
nature and just you know learn how to
start a fire
maybe maybe hunt some no they need to go
to the hood yeah south america i mean i
mean i would say i would say that the
jungle they need to come hang out in
trenton new jersey in the jungles that's
what they need to do
they need a field trip to the hood and
come live in the projects for a few
weeks it's so easy to get hurt in life
it's so easy to die it's so hard to live
and stay healthy like it is takes
everything that we can this all this i
don't think technology that we've built
modern medicine clean water
fresh air like it's so easy to die and
it's so easy
yeah you could there are so many things
that can kill you in this world and
there's so there's just like specific
ways to live why are you so negative
well i'm a real i'm realist i used to be
i think it's so easy to live
it is it's not in our world it is
because we have clothing and food that's
probably first world country capitalism
oh you're saying in some of the other
countries right oh yeah it's a fight
this is this is one of the problems we
have as a culture right now is that we
used to have to run full speed every day
and i mean figuratively to survive you
wake up you work you then as soon as the
sun goes down you're sleeping but you
work non-stop all day every day so check
this out
you keep talking about all these people
in this country to have a lower life
expectancy rate right it's because of
this iphone it's cause of our freedom
our the cost of our freedom is somebody
else's freedom
do you mean it's true the cost of united
states freedom is somebody all right so
whatever snickers you got on slaves in
china the slaves in china
our technology the slaves that's mining
the coltan the slaves that's mining the
gold
there's always going to be somebody's
freedom that's taken for yours well for
your luxury because we don't need the
phone you you can go live in the middle
of the woods and you know make a mud hut
you could
you could but it's easier not to
right
very a lot easier not to this is that's
a very hard life to live this is what's
funny about when people criticize the
left
saying things like you use an iphone you
use his computer right and they then
they have this comic where they're like
oh i'll partici you know participate in
society or whatever some stupid comic
yeah they think that they're allowed to
use these things that cause suffering
around the world because they're more
effective and better off with them they
don't understand
that
you want to complain about the the
millionaires the billionaires the big
corporations the exploitation you want
to complain about capitalism and then
use all of the fruits of how capitalism
enriches your life and makes it easier
yeah but you choose to do it at any
point you could say no
they don't want to they don't want to
they want the luxury they want the
luxury they want to complain about it to
see them like you know what it is it's
guilt
they're like i feel really bad that the
people at the foxconn labs are walking
off the building in mass suicide yeah
i'll complain about it but i'll keep
using the phone yeah that's why i tell
people like when people say oh i love
america i'm like you don't love america
you love the luxury of america yeah you
love the fact that you know we we take a
dump in water right yeah like that's
what you love you love that running
water you love that electricity you love
that wi-fi
you love that beer you love that bread
and circus fast food man yeah that's
what you love you love the luxury of
america you love the fact that we don't
got to deal with mosquitoes like that
and if we did we could just buy a can of
off
yep the conveniences of living in
america but all of that comes at the
expense of somebody else's freedom man
or it comes at the expense of nature but
we're trying to change that like one of
the okay one of the big moves or i think
one of the big drivers of you know
trump's base is
bringing manufacturing and and back to
america and yeah becoming more reliant
on ourselves and our community yes
brilliant brilliant thing to do
donald trump's the best president we've
ever had do you think so he is the best
president we've ever had at least in my
lifetime yeah i think that's a fair
point actually you know at least in my
lifetime there's a lot of things he was
bad about in terms of character and
demeanor but in terms of these past
couple of years we're dealing with
pulling our troops out and that to me
was like great on foreign policy into no
new wars amazing right wow we could do
that i didn't even know that was a
possibility
but it was just a thing that happened
like america would slip and fall and
drop a missile on you know foreign
we were close to it because he brought
bolton
bolton right we'd be celebrating in
tehran yeah
i mean uh i think i want to say under
clinton and maybe even bush um
you know the the
late 90s and the early 2000s was kind of
good man you could leave a job and walk
right into another one the economy was
coming in too good economy great great
economy economy ain't looked that well
in a long time no uh under trump it was
better it was
yeah to quote jim cramer well i mean i
lived that
yeah i lived that tim
it's one thing it's one thing to study
what they say it's another thing to live
in the late 90s and the early 2000s
anecdotal evidence i don't know let me
tell you this
in the in in the late 90s i was only
able to get like one power ranger action
figure but for some reason now that i'm
34 i could buy all of them
the economy must be
it seems like the economy is falling
apart right now with our oh that's so
good in the national debt yeah well it's
not just that it's kovit kobe it's
killing it i'll tell you this i'll tell
you this the debt though they just had
they just had the cdc director on i'm
pretty sure he was saying we never said
the lock down shut down schools we never
said to do this and new york's like
they're gonna do it anyway it's like
whoa whoa whoa why
why why why is new york shutting down
the schools when the cdc's never
recommended that
because then the parents can't go to
work why so why would they do this
[ __ ] the economy yeah it's crippling
the economy i'm not going to say they're
doing it on purpose but man these people
they must know what they're doing
destroying the economy they want they
want they want um they want bigger rent
they want you to know why you need them
well check this out
if we remove the little guy you know his
little mom and pop shop and all of that
and we make this amazon monopoly come
about who will spend money and doesn't
care if they lose money yeah that's
crazy right then i can charge them a
premium and rent and then you know real
estate goes up in this area and all of
these people are invested in real estate
and invested in these companies and so
are these you know
you know you know the amazon store in
seattle the one where you okay so you
sign up when you walk in the cameras
scan you yeah take whatever you want and
you walk out and it charges you right
right so i did this bit where i went and
figured out how to actually walk out
without getting charged for any goods
very easily how'd you do that so uh
i already released information before
and i'll tell you this when people learn
how a magic trick is done it loses the
magic yes but it really is very simple
so i i when i saw that they they
launched this store i'll tell you the
first part the first point i want to
make
when i discovered how to easily steal
whatever i want without being tracked i
called and asked for a comment and the
response i got was basically we don't
care about shoplifting because we make
so much money that if some you could
steal everything and we still make more
money yes they were like by not hiring
anybody we're making ridiculous profits
stealing means nothing to us yeah and
and shortages accounted for anyway
exactly so they put in the price and so
they're like we don't care that you
figure this out and i was like shrinkage
i'm sorry it was so easy to do anybody
could do it right now and they're like
we literally don't care yeah so here's
how you do it it's really simple
you just have someone else fill up a bag
and then you pick the bag up and walk
out
and it doesn't charge you
because they're tracking the bag not
what's in it so if someone fills a bag
up and then you pick it up and walk out
with it and then the person walks out
with no bag no one gets charged oh
that's amazing yeah so don't do that by
the way hey my people out there trying
to get reparations no no no
but the point was they told me they were
they were like the funny thing was they
kind of freaked out when they found out
i did it because i filmed a video on it
yeah and i showed like my app said
nothing was was charged and
i made sure something got charged on
purpose so you could see that i had a
receipt it was like a pack of gum right
and i was like but you can clearly see
we got a bunch of stuff but we did pay
for it i didn't steal anything right
what we did was we just swapped bags to
see if it would work okay and so they
basically were like wait a minute did
you swap bags with someone and i was
like yes and they were like oh and i was
like but you realize that allows people
to walk out like oh of course but
you know we don't care exactly we make
so much money we just don't and that's
and that's and that's exactly who they
want to replace new york real estate
with yeah people who got money to burn
and then you know what's crazy i was
talking to my friend about covet
lockdown and he said we need a lockdown
we need to lock down now hard and the
government needs to just pay everybody
to stay home
and i said where do you think that money
comes from and he goes the taxpayer and
i was like even if that was the case do
you know where the money is going it's
going to big box stores it's going to
amazon yeah it is the largest trade
wealth transfer ever in history
if if all they did was print money then
they're diluting your your money and
your savings taking your job away so you
can't make money then giving it all to
the ultra wealthy major monopolies yeah
if it was just taxpayer dollars and he
was like no it's taxpayer dollars
they're giving it back to the people and
then the people give it right back to
amazon because mom and pop shops are
closed yeah so you're transferring your
wealth to amazon they don't care about
losing money they got too much and
they're going to buy up these buildings
and they're going to replace all these
stores and it's going to be owned by a
small handful of people poor people make
poor decisions
i think so i think i think uh it's it's
broad but it is
generally true but the way i put it is a
person is smart people are stupid
a person is smart people people are
stupid
to quote it's from men in black
yeah he says a person is smart people
are dumb panicky animals yeah especially
when you put them together in packs
yeah they tend to
infect each other with the same
ignorance
yeah so he wants a lockdown that's
that's my big problem with the lock down
the lockdowns it's like
a lot of governments aren't even saying
that like i saw like two black people
blue checks like oh we need another lock
ban i'm like for what
if you are afraid of the covet virus
don't come outside lock yourself down
quarantine yourself i'll tell you this
man this is the libertarian versus
authoritarian i'm not saying everybody
who wants a lockdown is a hardcore
authoritarian they might just not be
very smart or it might be the one issue
but
i remember when they banned cigarettes
in chicago from bars and i didn't
understand it they were like they're
gonna pass a city-wide ordinance you
can't smoke in restaurants or bars
anymore and i was like i don't
understand why why why are they doing
that yeah because i don't smoke i hate
smoking because it's effective somebody
else's health sure sure but
i i've i tried smoking when i was a kid
everyone's like here try a cigarette i
tried a cigarette don't like it i don't
want to smoke don't smoke i don't smoke
weed i don't i used to drink i don't
drink right i don't tell people they
can't do it and so if i go to an
establishment and they say
you want to smoke and people are smoking
and i don't like it you know what i do i
just leave i leave right it's really
simple yeah it's not very hard i just
walk out yeah yeah so i i totally agree
with that you know i like i like i like
boltons you know because sometimes
you're at a family restaurant and it's
like oh yeah i got a smoking section and
it's just like maybe restaurants should
have been the ones to dictate that right
but um i think if they lose the business
because families don't want to go there
go yeah exactly somebody should and
that's that's why i say like
that ruins capitalism right yeah you
come in you set this ordinance that says
hey you know smoking's bad for everybody
when you could have just waited for some
capitals and say hey look we don't allow
smoking in our building
everybody come here and then all the
non-smokers will go there and then
smokers will go here and everybody's
happy you know i think what happened is
they would slowly start making the
smoking areas smaller and further away
but i guess you know the difference
between smokers and non-smokers is what
is it smokers tip better
they tip better oh yes really smokers
used to tip better bro really why is
that
uh because they're cooler people oh yeah
that explains it yeah i mean these are
these are people that are cool down to
earth they kind of smoke
i used to okay i smoke weed every now
and then um
i'll have a cigarette every now and then
if i'm having alcohol like you know
whatever whatever but i'm not a smoker i
used to be a smoker but nah man you know
uh
you know non-smokers tend to be like you
know real snooty and
you know is that that white is that how
i got you smoke right i've
we
yep it's been a while though i'm i'm
uptight and snooty and arrogant yeah me
too how dare you sir come into my home
with your cigarettes
yeah
so we got that puritan movement that was
in you know it's heavy in the united
states and in some ways i agree in some
ways i don't and i agree in a lot of
ways culturally but when they start like
legislating stuff i'm like ah that's
where i'm partnering with you man it's
it's you know
there's it's it's not just uh one way or
the other it's not it's not black or
white there's nuance
some things that make sense to say you
can't do like as best as maybe you know
what i mean right because people aren't
aren't realizing that's around them yeah
and then all sudden you get some
something happens people get sick
there's also the issue when it comes to
smoking
i can understand the point i don't
necessarily agree with it that people
don't realize how much damage they're
doing
by having these establishments where
people smoke yeah for instance you might
not mind smoking right you might not
mind the smoke from other people right
but it's messing you up a little bit yes
so you go into the bar and you're like i
don't care doesn't bother me but now
it's creating a net negative for you
know for everybody else indeed but the
problem i have with that is the logical
conclusion is to just take everything
take anything pleasurable just you know
lock people down and that that's to me
that's just it's ridiculous you look you
remember what bloomberg did when he
banned soda large sodas what what do you
do michael bloomberg in new york banned
large soda right i'm pretty sure he did
i don't know if you can yeah i remember
yeah yeah yeah and then unity said when
he was asked about it taxed the poor
he said the poor make poor people make
poor decisions he basically said that he
said you've got all these poor people
that waste their money on things that
are bad for their health and if we were
managing their lives for them they'd be
better off mm-hmm yeah yeah
i mean the government the government
just just
they suck at holding you know some
people accountable which is why they
shouldn't be allowed to make these
decisions because if it was me i would
just ban soda period like look don't
sell no don't sell no still sold on my
steak done
you would ban soda i'd ban soda i mean
if i was an evil dictator right right oh
i'd ban cilantro
get it out just get rid of it yeah
i know i
i go back and forth with you know the
the existence of this state i'm like i
don't like the existence of the state
but if i'm dictator oh yeah so
so so hold on here's the here's always
the big challenge right do you think
china is doing their best to to dominate
to take over to seize power and land and
resources oh they're doing such a great
job so what would happen if we didn't
have the state they just walk right in
what do you mean walk right in they
already took over they
walk right in well joe biden's pres uh
president-elect they said so you know i
guess so they own our debt they trade
our debt they own land they don't eat
large swaths of land in the western u.s
chinese military on every corner you
can't even buy something that's not from
china like what do you mean like well
well i got this uh aren't my pillows
from america they are from america yeah
yeah i got one of those
things mike yeah you know my pillow yeah
the pillow part what part of it is from
america and what part of it is wait he's
got the uh the giza sheets from from
from egypt oh okay
no i'm pretty sure they make the whole
thing in america nice that's it here as
well yeah yeah props to stuff like that
right so if people really cared
like those industries would thrive
people say look let's start with pillows
right the great pillow revolution
and then everybody just slowly transfer
that right i think we need to start with
shoes
if you want if you want to screw over
china start with shoes yep discovered
plastic and graphene you wanna you want
something yeah i like that too yeah you
wanna hear something crazy who's that
you wanna know how they make skateboards
oh the wood comes from typically canada
okay they send it to china
they cut it and turn it to a skateboard
and ship it to california
amazing what is china doing that we
can't do i'm going to tell you what
listen listen what this is what's crazy
yeah it is cheaper because of the labor
costs yes to get the wood from canada
ship it thousands of miles to china yeah
then thousands of miles back because
people in america for labor cost too
much money
no because we have something called
minimum wage yeah
but that's the problem and china doesn't
have no minimum wage they're going to
pay you whatever the heck to get it done
and i like that no no i think you know
what it might be but it might be free
trade
how so
so if we just said
if a skateboard is being imported and it
costs it is undercutting american goods
we put a tariff on it
yeah that's one way to do it you know
but again that's like utilizing the
government i just say
you know um
let people
like repeal these laws like repeal
minimum wage and then that becomes a
school project what if kids in schools
for school projects made skateboards and
every kid that wanted to make
skateboards
spent an hour making sp skateboards a
day all across the nation it's pretty
fun right like what if that was a job
for skateboarders like yo bro you want
to really rad
work for a day in in in you know like
there's ways that these things can
happen and besides machines are going to
do it so you really just feed it into a
machine and the machine skateboards work
i don't know i don't know if they do it
that way
is there some hand
hand tooling yeah so you you put it's
the seven layers of wood and then they
have a mold and they put the glue on it
and then they press it and they hold it
down for a certain amount of time okay i
i they probably have some kind of mass
production process for sure especially
in china yeah you know you know the big
problem is though
is that very obviously and uh with all
due respect the boards that come out of
china are not good no kidding like i
could imagine they're just trying to
meet me to quota and shout out and ship
them out as i said you gotta have people
who like actually care about it if a
skateboarder made the skateboard
everyone would come out perfect
you know but the big companies that know
how to do it get the labor and
everything done in china those are
really really those are the best okay so
when the wood comes from u.s or canadian
rock maple and gets sent over and then
press and everything sent back and they
quality test it and they know so when
does the when does the tim pool
skateboarding manufacturing company come
actually yeah we're gonna do it we're
totally doing it that's dope thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8 pm so come back to
check us out when we go live don't
forget to subscribe hit the like button
hit the notification bell and we are
also available on all podcast platforms
for free if you want to listen to us
there thanks for hanging out and we will
see you all next time